roshia elige hoy alcaldes gobernadores
concejales en parte del país en torno a
78 mil puestos electivos están en juego
pero para la oposición rusa son unas
elecciones atípicas son las primeras que
se celebran después del envenenamiento
de aleccionaban y que todavía está
recuperándose en alemania y parece que
le queda mucho por delante en todo caso
van a poner en marcha una estrategia muy
similar a la del año pasado en las
elecciones locales de aquí de moscú el
llamado smart boat en el voto
inteligente consiste en aquellos lugares
donde no les han dejado presentarse
redirigir el voto desde internet hacia
otras opciones de la oposición aunque no
les gusten aquellas que tienen más
posibilidades de quitar votos al partido
gubernamental rusia unida a quienes
funcionó y consiguieron que rusia unida
perdiese casi un tercio de sus
representantes lo que está por ver es si
esta estrategia de voto redirigido y
coaliciones con otros partidos
opositores minoritarios va a funcionar
esta vez a los seguidores huérfanos de
alexéi navalni